two robots and love no I'm happy to be
here forever brand deal that you have
something didn't know now you know your
life is different now I'm in the kitchen
with Eliot see Morgan the C stands for
huge we're back doing another hellofresh
video the last time you were here
fun for the whole family Step five has
been accomplished this time we're doing
it sober it's an excuse for me to cook
with Elliott in the kitchen
and do a very romantic thing that
couples do you want like candles or just
be redundant with all this fire we
already have Fire Department haven't
shown up yet to has their hazards to
happen what are we doing today Eliot
race today we're going to make the big
boss burger from hello fresh yeah I
would love to know more about hello
fresh personally you know how to find
over 22 seasonal chef curated recipes at
the drop of a hat how do I do that
let me tell you it is grace but before I
do you are wanting something that's
locality or vegetarian you're not sure
where to go where do I go well I'll tell
you in just a second have you ever
wondered what meal service has more
five-star kids I wonder it all day
great news grace first let me ask you
something are you tired of distressful
meal planning and prepping because it's
hellofresh Wow excuse me to pick up my
panties that just dropped Wow
nursing them yeah where I'm on the
outside oh yeah uh hello fresh is a meal
delivery service that's brought straight
to your door Evan pick out your meals
online they have over 22 seasonal chef
curated recipes become with step-by-step
instructions along with pre-portioned
ingredients so you can put them all
together and still get the joy of
cooking without the stress of messes or
not knowing what you're doing and each
time it comes up absolutely delicious
get yourself a boyfriend that can do
your ad reads for you I have to say this
is a very sexy experience that sexy
grace well let me tell you about
something else
hello freshers carbon footprint is 25%
lower than those store-bought grocery
items Wow not only are you helping and
you know what's a fun phrase for sex
there's six steps in every hellofresh
recipe we're not drinking this video
because we're better than you that
doesn't mean you don't have to sound
normal built-in to drink every time I
shop or drink when I don't stuff you
drink at your own pace on your own terms
both of us are also very starving so
this is actually as practical as much as
it is entertainment for you prep and
make special sauce you know what you can
call sex making special sauce preheat
the oven to 425 degrees get that up and
nice and hot we're doing it we're doing
kitchen sex do you want to like wash
your head you need to make the meal come
in this lovely package oh no eggs
there's a joke about a barren uterus
somewhere in there
a barren uterus I said no way oh you're
gonna peel and slice this onion into
rings cuz we're gonna make onion rings
I'm gonna thinly slice the pickle into
rounds yeah I got a knife out of here
the most polite murderer of all time I
mean talk about wrap it up I love
pickles so much although my Jersey is
showing I'm gonna have this lemon look
it's like wow like Benihana yeah you've
seen it you're gonna combine all the
sour cream and ketchup and mustard what
do you need to practice safe cooking
condoms mints I'll see myself out
you would think this would be more
sexual than it is and he'll be with your
mustard hey you a girlfriend who will
help you with your mustard you can't get
half of the garlic powder
oh well kissing shy or a teaspoon of
sugar I don't have sugar but I do have
Splenda and that's how to put it all my
ask for sugar are you okay with that yes
I am thank you for asking always ask for
consent this is real cooking great you
did it I got I got lost and toast the
bun you're now on to step two gonna cook
the bacon we're bacon
oh we do it bacon oh it's okay i got a
flashbac to like north great reminds me
of like in collars they put cats and
things like this you don't it looks like
a very stretched uterus goes in the oven
for 10 to 15 minutes to crisp up and
while the bacon cooks we're gonna form
the beef into two equal sized patties
I'm gonna watch you handle the meat all
day oh it's the most condescending
really working that sound of the meat
swapping through your fingers was louder
than your whispers no seasoned with salt
and pepper meanwhile I'm gonna go on to
step three which means we're in killing
this in a large bowl I'm gonna whisk
together the tempura mix half a teaspoon
of salt and a third cup of cold water
done those who say during date it's good
to use your teeth
third of water look we're mixing it okay
suppose we pancake batter like
consistence for your pancake batter yeah
now we're gonna toss our onion rings
with the fry seasoning this is very cute
we're guessing cooking is like it's like
a relationship you just sort of like
guess along the way and then we stir
into the batter until fully coated good
luck keep your handsome getting dirty oh
yeah you knew wait to put a third inch
of oil and a large heavy bottomed pan
over medium-high heat when the oil is
hot enough we put our onion rings in oh
yes we do or make it to nine new rings
I'll just be over here touching these
onions all weird Oh what we can do is
get ready to cook our burgers drizzle of
oil in the other pan and put that on
some medium heat that can heat up so we
can put our burgers in there may as well
what else we doing I'm there
and we're sober in fairness I smoked a
little bit great you did it I got a loss
I don't know you think he's waiting for
me to put a ring on it
okay wow they're touching girl touching
I can't get this out touch it one of the
cool things about hellofresh is that you
can skip a week if you would like to
just put the burgers in this is kind of
where the panic starts to set it like
every good relationship there's a moment
that gets very tense and very heated
it's all how you manage it together yes
we're not reinventing the wheel we're
basically just making burgers but we're
doing it together little tip when you're
cooking with your partner make sure you
stay hydrated it's always nice to make
the lady a nice tall glass of water what
are you guys doing for Valentine's Day I
think we're going out to eat
do you like Valentine's Day pants do you
pair no oh my god I'm getting excited
now I am in the bedroom before things
get started let them into our life a
little bit no in turn burgers robust
okay we're gonna finish up and place
these burgers and we'll make it back
you're gonna see the final result
I killed the spire that's put this me
into these buns I am in the bed happy
Valentine's Day you clean up I'm gonna
clean up you clean up I'm gonna clean up
that's after sex both of our parents
watch these videos I'll ever use one pan
within another pan this is what a
relationship in 2020 looks like yeah
this is our Instagram photo this is her
tagged photo yeah that's good that's
good that's good
really good Wow Wow I do feel like a
boss do you feel like a boss so much
better thank you so much it's not as
much so much to me guys if you would
like to take part in this fun and get
ten free meals along with free shipping
you can go to hellofresh calm and use
the code grace helbig ten on wet thank
you guys so much for watching make sure
you go check out elliot off the valley
folk and go see him do stand-up live is
all the links to it and all of this
social medias with that Elliott Morgan
across the board here's me do you guys
next time like this video give it a
thumbs up let me know if you're making
any hello fresh meals or who gives I
don't know don't touch me that's after
sex